we give out a couple hundred thousand
dollars worth of toys a year
it just gives you a break from from what
we're going through you know there's
people out there who care
[Music]
you don't even notice what you're doing
but like it really could change
someone's life he sent like a whole
truck with like a band
[Music]
the joy was immense just to see the
smile on the faces of the family
[Music]
sometimes
this is a place where children adults
and families of
ill children disabled children special
needs
and so on to come and have a safe place
to come play
private place it's not a public's not
open to the public it's just for them
and their families
the amazing volunteers here you see over
here each from one
they give hours and hours of their time
i see all these games here check them
out check it out what's going on here
hi rafael hey rafal how are you
good to see you this is a family the boy
family right here nice to meet you
we go to hospitals and we go visit sick
children all the time
and houses so these all these costumes
here you see that elephant they had a
huge elephant
right and all these different blow up
costumes all that stuff this is stuff
that we use volunteers hundreds of
volunteers go to many children's
hospitals
sometimes even non-jew children too
that's for we help everyone with this
we go to hospitals we give it out we go
to houses we give out children come here
we give it out
we give out a couple hundred thousand
dollars worth of toys a year
this guy who just walked in there that
skinny guy his name is shulam lemmer
he's a hasidic guy who was signed by
universal as i told you
he's going to be singing that this guy
right here oh wow
this is a beautiful space where it gives
um
you know unfortunate unhealthy kids an
opportunity to feel like everyone else
just seeing their faces light up and
smiling and the parents telling me
you know they had treatments the entire
day and this is the biggest smile
they've had in weeks and
just makes you want to do it again and
again and again
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
when you have an organization like this
that really allows families to come here
do their thing enjoy each other's
company just have a good time let the
hear down figuratively
um i think it's something unbelievable
it's why i'm part of this organization
for many years
when it comes to music there seems to be
a certain level of comfort that it
creates
and it also inspires people to you know
to get out of bed sometimes or to smile
i mean i've been i've been in people's
houses where you had a 10 year old kid
just came back after weeks of chemo in
the hospital setting
they're at home for the first time we
did a birthday for them just to see the
smile on the faces of the family
sometimes
their siblings and the comforter brings
them is unbelievable
most of the kids have had cancer or
going through cancer
chemo um there's plenty of people that
just have debilitating diseases
that will never recover and this is
their moment
i see
[Music]
is
yeah i think i can fit in here you got
this he got this he got this
all right
here we go his name is jumpy green okay
jumpy green yeah that's his name what's
up he's our he's our
recording studio director studio
director right here but they come in
they like music they enjoy music so they
come in here to the studio we sit there
we record with them they come by the mic
we play some soundtracks we have
fun with them and we have a good time
basically with them and then we send out
the songs to their family members and
everything so they could have a
nice experience and a fun time
[Music]
so then the kid will come we'll tell him
what to do and he'll sit down with me
and we'll make a full track together
so i studied in lakewood when i was
about 16 17 years old we're talking 10
years ago
and this organization had just started
then but
there were literally waiting lists of
people who wanted to volunteer here and
they just couldn't handle the volume of
people who wanted a volunteer
i'm not sure it's still the same today
but i imagine it is you come here right
mr max
right right why is it amazing
organization because it's fun
it's fun miss america takes kids and
families that have sick children
in any sort of way people that are in
and out of the hospital people that
aren't
all different things and they give them
the most amazing time that they can have
in the world they call me up they're
like listen you're a juggler right i
said yeah i'm a juggler
like all right you go down to this house
i come in this
a huge party going on there's like 20
guys there right they're dancing they're
singing there's a sick boy sitting on
the couch with cancer
and his family's there they're all just
watching the joy
was immense i was swept up i got up
there i juggled
i did my thing i danced and from then
i'm i'm here i'm 22.
how's that 10 years later i'm still here
thank god i've been volunteering mr mac
for 7 years by now
and people ask me like you know you make
a kid smile you know does that really
change his life does it really make a
difference you know it's for is it just
for the moment
so i have a story i would love to share
with you with the world we had a little
girl
she was four or five i don't remember
exactly the age she was in the hospital
she
went through a terrible illness not
something no one should ever know about
you know and
and she was there and we came to try to
you know make a little happy little
music and we had a couple clowns there
and one of the prizes they gave her was
a roll of stickers and this girl hasn't
spoken in
in over a year she lost her ability to
speak and they were trying to you know
therapy try to bring it back and they
couldn't do it one of the volunteers
handed her a little sticker she's
looking at it
and she put it up to her mouth and we
had i think was someone on a trumpet
who's sitting there playing
and she puts it up into her mouth and
goes into the roll of the stickers
and she looked around at her mother and
she's like wait like this is a girl that
hasn't spoken hadn't made a sound in a
long time she went too and she was like
dude and like it kind of brought back
the memory she wasn't
the injury wasn't in her mouth the
injury wasn't you know it was it was a
mental illness and
and that prevented her from having that
ability but like you know she started
getting back to words and she started
she
she knew what to say she didn't know how
to verbalize it and it's kind of brought
back her ability to be able to verbalize
and bring it back
you know it took time till the words
were clear again right but like she she
learned how to express herself with her
mouth
and just from a little too so you know
we kind of think like you know we're
just making someone laugh making someone
smile you don't realize
the significance of how much you can do
to someone you don't even notice what
you're doing but like it really could
change someone's life
how has this institution been for you as
a
family as a parent has it been a
huge impact in your life it's definitely
been much easier
to deal with our struggles and like
everything that we're going through
being that we know that we have
this organization that you know like
even during covet for example when like
we were all alone in the house and like
we couldn't get out or go anywhere
like he sent like a whole truck with
like a band
like playing music with a band like a
whole band
to outside he drove by they came outside
we were able to get out and just to like
have some like life you know what i'm
saying and he didn't do it once he did
it twice he had like another
another like famous singer came by and
he's saying
like we do like social distance and it
was just really nice to know that
you know we have such
like such such a caring like um
community you know what i'm saying
like like my wife was saying before
during the heavy time of kobe when we
were locked up in a house
we were actually quarantined because of
my son also he called us up he goes come
outside and a half hour
there's going to be an open truck and
there was live music on there there were
singers everyone was far away from each
other
they came actually in a full body suit
this was funny and they were singing we
were dancing outside on the lawn you
know me and my sons
and we just you know it just gives you a
break from from what we're going through
you know there's people out there who
care
my son just had his 15th birthday we
didn't have to call up he called us up
because i know it's his birthday
bring him over let me get live music let
me get some singers over here you kids
could enjoy it bring some friends over
and it was a beautiful beautiful i think
it was a sunday if when i was taking
then
people came over and just you know like
something that we wouldn't be able to do
on our own
or at home now we were able to do over
here and
you know there's no place like it so
it's changed your life in a positive way
100 percent
[Music]
we also have sunday nights we have girls
that are over 18
that are either born with a disability
or handicapped or something like that
they come here and we do activities with
them we could do paint night or
making flowers or doing something fun
painting glass or whatever it may be a
lot of them don't have what to do so
much
you know they're post high school not
all of them have jobs
so they do come here and it gives them
an activity for the week like there's
one
16 year old girl that i'm very connected
to she doesn't come here often at all
but i actually go to her house all the
time she's bed bound she's bedridden
okay she always said and lost all her
mobility and muscles
and um i'm very close to her i'm close
to the family and
i feel like a family member to her yes
right now it's hard for her to talk
she loves me so do you feel like all
this
you can feel all this connection through
non-verbal communication right
yeah you don't need someone to talk to
you no for sure yeah
that's beautiful you don't run after
don't ask families for
money that's right we don't we don't ask
families for money we never ask them
here to enjoy the facility we don't ask
them for money we don't bother them at
all for that
i'm going to ask for money here if
anyone wants to donate to this beautiful
cause
that helps children that helps relieve
the stress of parents
i will leave what what is it what is the
name of the website
actually spreading smiles.org
spreadingsmiles.org
i will leave the link below guys thanks
for coming along on this this is a very
beautiful cause
pick anything small or large a dollar is
also meaningful guys
add it on amazon's smile that won't cost
you a dollar i won't cost you a cent and
every every purchase you make on amazon
go to smile.amazon.com every purchase
you make amazon will give us a point
five percent of your purchase
donated to our organization i'll leave
that link too thank you all okay
thank you audience coming along on that
another deep dive into the hasidic world
very interesting i'm going to get some
good sleep
and get back at it tomorrow in brooklyn
until next one
my